[Musique]
essayons de vraiment faire ce crescendo
david shiver ce violoniste professionnel
aime partager sa passion
chaque mardi depuis sept mois il donne
des cours de violon à l'école de musique
de buc le jongle un petit peu cette
année entre les entre les deux mais je
trouve quand même temps les deux
activités sont tout à fait
complémentaires c'est à dire que de
l'enseigné on apprend beaucoup en même
temps le fait de devoir expliquer ça
oblige à réfléchir à se poser des
questions et et c'est vrai que ça en
fait ça est dedans ça dans sa
progression en tant que musicien
ce soir-là il est deux apprentis
violoniste à maîtriser vivaldi dans deux
jours ils ont un examen ils mettent
beaucoup ouvrent donne des bons conseils
aux en violon des conseils de technique
des conseils pour quand on est sur scène
pour le sont pour comment rendre les
choses ou le morceau plus facile à jouer
[Musique]
le musicien franco américains fondent en
2016 l'ensemble continuum à versailles
une dizaine d'artistes amoureux de la
musique baroque et moderne
c'était un projet que j'avais en tête
déjà depuis longtemps
auparavant j'étais plutôt dans la
musique
enfin dite moderne c'est à dire que je
jouait du violon sur sur instruments
modernes
j'ai pris goût et passion pour la
musique ancienne
j'ai découvert ça progressivement on va
dire depuis à 10 ans à peu près j'ai
travaillé beaucoup avec avec john eliot
gardiner pour cette saison culturelle
ils sont en résidence à l'église notre
dame de la cité royale
ils seront en concert le 5 mai prochain
[Musique]